hello everybody my name is markiplier
it's currently 3 a.m. because I woke up
early and I'm still on Cincinnati time
my roommates are still asleep so I
decided that I was going to record a
let's play and make it the world's
quietest glad to play it sounds like
this pop rocks in my mouth because I
have the sensitivity turned up so high
in my microphone and I thought what
better game to play for the world why
I'm just gonna turn that a little away
from me there we go that's probably
better so I thought what better game to
play for the world's quietest let's play
then happy wheels and now I won't move
on to a sword throw or I will murder
these sons of [ __ ] eat a dick little
Johnny D 10 dicks why the [ __ ] did that
happen you son of a [ __ ] I will eat
your face once more under the breach of
my friends just remember pain is only a
temporary measure lady are you flirting
with me with the building up your butt
because I don't think you kindly do that
also I just noticed the lady showing me
her vagina that's inappropriate
an epic big ball throw because if
there's one thing that markiplier likes
its epic big balls I unlocked the win
and I received another ball an odd
medical condition to have an extra ball
but one that I will not complain about
because I'm a winner what I'm not ready
for a rope swing I was not told that I
was going to be doing a rope swing I'm
pretty sure this was not part of my
contract and frankly I hate everything
you stand for and everything that you
are frankly I believe that this is a
load of [ __ ] and I wish nothing but
held to rain down upon these stupid-ass
balls and everything to go wrong in
their life because I hate them then I'm
left with just one ball to my name my
life
I have two testicle suffering is all you
will get in this universe suffering is
all you will get in this area suffering
is all you will get because I don't know
it sounds a lot more sexual when I say
it's closed and this quietly [ __ ] me in
the bottle but not seriously like you
know
rayji way oh you all need to be much
quieter I'm murdering you because you
are not go ahead you're not quiet you
need to be quiet there is too much at
stake here
my roommates could wake up and leggo
will start barking like it was not quite
as good no Morpheus I know kung fu I
also know watermelon food for some
reason and I survived because I'm
amazing
[ __ ] the melon no don't [ __ ] the melon
whenever I say something like this
it sounds very sexual do not [ __ ] melons
but you know [ __ ] the melon I don't like
that not like this not like this another
come for a fight I gonna kill you well
mercy shall not be well [ __ ] me prepare
to eat a dick lastly I shall attempt
this rope swing [ __ ]
that's a good enough so thank you
everybody for joining me for the world's
cleanest let's play I hope you enjoyed
it and I hope you're having a wonderful
morning because I'm going to be awake
for a long long time by myself thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video